take care of quick journey are very very
first lesson together we had a look at
three dimensional a tree right it was
sustained stuff with right angle
triangles but we made things not just be
flat but like you're up into the air
like measure the height of a flagpole or
a tree or something like that okay so we
started with 3d we then move forward we
had a look at these things called exact
values there were particular angles
particular angles where when you do sign
or cause of those angles you get nice
neat numbers out that are exact rather
than like Missy read decimals like
science 71 does anyone remember what
those angles were we started with three
and then we added them to fun so we
start with 30 45 and 60 and then what we
did was for the next steps we added a
couple more which I'll talk about the
second from exact values we said these
angles right they're all acute they're
all the cute they're less than 90
degrees okay but we want to be able to
go past that so we introduce the unit
circle the unit circle we said you can
think about signing caused by thinking
about this guy and its coordinates
rather than just triangles right another
name for this which you might sometimes
see in different textbooks on revision
and chapters are angles of any magnitude
which is just another way of saying more
than 90 degrees okay once we did that we
added in here zero degrees and 90
degrees okay so for example sign 0 the 0
0 0 is 1 and we got all that off the
unit circle you can do the same thing to
90 degrees okay where do we move from
there we spent a lot of try and drawing
actually we've been doing a lot during
this topic okay in fact one of the key
skills I've trained military is that
visual component thinking visually so we
did all the draft graphs with inside
with it cause and then thinking about
sign and college and 10
we notice the verse trigonometric
function so post and their related to
each other they're not like just three
random things okay they are actually
connected and really important ways for
instance we learned that the reason y
cosine is called cosine is because the
co stands for compliments right so for
example sine 30 is equal to cos 1660
because 60 is the complement of 30 right
you can do that for any angle you could
say sign of 47 will because of what with
a cup of beer it's a bit hard up 43
right and you can go come on and or not
there are complimentary relationships
like this one there are also
supplementary relationships one of which
we noticed with the ambiguous case for
scien to remember that so for example
you could say i'll come back to sign 30
in sine 30 is also the same as sine 150
right and that's that's the ambiguous
case right there if you're trying to
find an angle to triangle and use the
same rule and 30 degrees as an answer
150 degrees will also be in it so those
are the relationships we spend some time
solving trigonometric equations like 10
x equals negative 1 what are the
solution is that how many solutions are
there ok cos x equals reach me on two
etc etc and then the last thing we've
kind of finished off with is all of this
measurement stuff in triangles that are
right angle ok so in order we learn the
same rule then we learned our cosine
rule and today we've learnt about the
area of a triangle and all of these are
called
no one right-angled triangles
ok
and then we stopped there's a lot isn't
there right do you ever want to showed
you that table at the beginning of armed
our lessons rest up look at all these
connections that are happening okay let
me try to explain why this is happening
in general Matt's right and you don't
have to wreck us now but I'm going
through just because it'll make it
easier for me to illustrate to you right
in general mass treat does one thing
trig stays in trying clothes okay tree
stays in triangle yes I think that's
pretty common sense right because
trigonometry means the measurement of
triangles ok but into unit we learn the
tree can do much more okay in fact
primarily we use it to model the
physical world you remember how when we
looked at graphs wraps the sine graph
looks like this goes up and down and up
and down up and down so anything in
nature and it turns out there's lots of
things that go up and down up and down
and up and down like this you can model
with trig okay example the tides of the
beach they've your up and down in this
pattern okay um you know how when you
came in this morning Adam 745 his son
was up okay and it was reasonably bright
and the Sun was quite high in the sky
okay in the middle of July it's
substantially lower and a lot darker
right if you go through the times in the
year like toy the days in the year and
you just take a picture of how high the
Sun is at a particular time website 745
it goes up and it goes down exactly in
this pattern right you guys do science
and physics radio waves light waves all
of them they go up and down up and down
exactly like this okay so in order to
understand all of that you need all this
extra tree that's why we do it now
because it leads into tuna next week
okay just to give you one more
illustration I thought rigs a bit like a
smartphone okay or you just call in
phones these days because no one uses
together kind right if you've got
parents and like they've only just
recently upgraded to a smartphone right
um they think that all this kind of
thing does is like it makes calls and it
sends texts right that's all it does and
you're like no I read it does like
that's only two percent of what i use
this thing for right i use
for all these other things thinking that
tree right or only stays in triangles is
like thinking this thing only makes
calls and send texts it does so much
more than that right and your parents
say but I have to learn all this other
stuff like after what's up how do you
even what does it even mean okay are all
these extra skills open up a whole new
world okay